Instead of having P-squared threads to compute P-squared force interactions
and then summing them up between threads, we'll only use P threads total.
Each of these P threads will then be responsible for P interactions.
Another way to think about it is that 1 thread, this horizontal thread here,
is responsible for applying the force of all P source objects to 1 destination object.
So the code for this is really simple, and we're showing it here.
Our kernel code simply loops N over P times over this particular routine.
It accumulates P by P interactions onto P threads in each iteration.
So what's happening in this code?
Well the input to the kernel is my parameters, those associated with my destination object.
Those would be say, your position and your mass or your charge
and the accumulated force that has acted on my object so far.
And the output will be the accumulated force after I add in P more interactions,
1 for each of the source objects with which I'm interacting.
So we assume that we store parameters for the P source objects in shared memory,
sourceParams here,
and then we just loop P times over those P objects.
We compute the interaction, and this might be computation of gravitational force, it might be electrostatic force,
and the params will differ depending on what kind of force it is.
And then we'll compute the interaction and add resulting force into the force accumulator variable and return it.